well sean i'm very impressed i listened
to the album
it's amazing because you wrote or
co-wrote every single song
on the album if you could describe the
journey that you want to take your fans
on
as they listen what would you want them
to understand about who you are and
like where you are in your life right
now
big question i know we're going in hot
no i mean it's it's a it's a great
question and it's it's actually probably
the only question
anyone would ever ask to have to ask
when
releasing an album because really the
album is like a reflection of
my life at the moment you know or my
life i guess i should say rather
over the last six seven months
you know i think for me i had a big
moment of
anxiety and fear and i and i felt like i
wasn't able to make music at the top of
the year and um i think that was all
coming from a place of
fear of of uh people not liking the
music i made and it was kind of
choking me as a songwriter or fear of
maybe not being able to make music
better than i made in the past so i gave
myself a month
to kind of think if i figure out what
was at the bottom of that and i had a
lot of
fear regarding my art and
i found a place after a lot of work and
a lot of kind of
self meditation and and journaling and a
bunch of different
fun things that helped me um where i
i went in and i started making an album
and i
just went in with the thing of like hey
like this is it i showed up i'm here
to make music i'm here to make art and
if it happens
in the best way it does and if it
doesn't happen then it doesn't and i i
don't really have control
and ironically when i freed myself from
that expectation
i think i started making my favorite art
i've ever made in my life i mean i don't
think i know i
really feel like i created an
album that feels like
freedom and i keep saying the word
freedom but i know the album is called
wonder
and wonder was an essence of it that i
was trying to face fine but like
i felt very free just making it i felt
like this is
music i love to listen to this is music
i want to hear this is music i want to
make and
um i think it's gorgeous for that reason
i
asked him if he wanted to be famous one
day and he
like shut the whole idea down so fast in
your documentary
your sister said you did not want to be
famous when you were younger now you are
a superstar you are free to make
any sort of music that you want what is
your relationship like
with fame these days now that you have
attained this
crazy level of it i think my
relationship with it is that
it's a funny and weird and uncomfortable
thing
but the beautiful thing about fame is
that it allows you to have a voice
to get messages across that need to be
heard and i think
uh that's a level of my career that i've
wanted to step into
in the past but i felt like was lacking
courage to do
and i started a foundation over the last
couple years
that we've been working on and it's just
like i realized that
all of the music and all the all of the
fame and and the videos and the photos
and everything kind of combined
creates a platform to be able to send a
really really
powerful message in so many different
ways so
fame is something that
you can't just get if you ask for it
it's something that i think happens to
people and there's no really answer why
or reason why and
it's been something that's really been a
blessing in my life after i realized i
can use it for some really beautiful
things
[Music]
you um and justin bieber kind of talk
about the struggles of fame
in the song monster he's been very open
about what he's been through
i mean since he was literally 15 years
old
did he give you any advice or talk to
you about anything that he's been
through
totally i mean i think he was really um
he's been i mean the thing about him is
that he's he's gone through a lot and i
feel like he's
really come out on the other end in a
place where he
realizes how much of a blessing it is to
do what we do for a living
and on top of that he also realizes that
like
there is darkness and there's heavy
things that happen in our
career but the truth is that in any
industry it's the same thing and i feel
like
from him there's this constant
conversation of like
we're i'm grateful and we're blessed
like look at what's going on around us
and i
even woke up this morning and i have i
had a lot on my schedule and i
reminded myself like oh i'm really like
all i'm doing is getting on a zoom call
to be like
i made an album about things that i love
and like
talk about things that mean something to
me and i really comparatively to what i
could be doing
and doing something that is from heaven
you know and i think
the interesting thing about monster is
that this song i actually wrote three
years ago when i was feeling a lot of
society and pressure and whatever who
who i was in a relationship with and
wanting to push me into this box and i
felt a lot of that pressure
and three years later i actually
listened back to it and it makes me
think of
every single person who has instagram or
twitter and every single person who
is checking their instagram every five
minutes to see if people approve
of the last thing they posted and it's
tough because
there is this society pressure that
everyone has on each is putting on each
other and
something that is so true and i don't
think is talked about enough is that the
human condition is messy and like
since we're babies we fall and we learn
that's how we don't do something again
and that's how we grow
and i think as adults like i don't know
who decided that we're not allowed just
to keep learning and to fall and i think
it was a message that i wanted to get
across in the song and it's the message
i want to get across right now and every
day moving forward that like
we gotta just be okay with being messy
and falling and if somebody
falls like don't push them down don't
put your foot on top of them
like help them up and teach them because
i think it's
it's the way that culture can really be
there for each other and
it's a beautiful thing for that reason
[Music]
this album and also your documentary um
covers your relationship with camila
cabello i think so
beautifully who is more mushy
when it comes to songwriting i think
we're both equally
very mushy and i think we're both
extremely mushy people
we're both super sensitive which is
creates a lot of sensitive sensitivity
in our relationship
but we are songwriters so we're
constantly searching for the sensitive
topics in the life
and um i don't know i'm pretty mushy i
i when i don't know what she wouldn't
how she would answer that i feel like
she would maybe say i'm much more
mushy that's kind of cute though yeah
are there topics that you guys have both
agreed to not
write about when it comes to the
relationship
no we don't really put any rules or
boundaries i think on
our what we're writing about or our
art or even just i think i think the
truth about
being celebrities and being in a
relationship is that it's super tricky
because
there's a lot of people who want to know
more than maybe is
normal to give out they want more
personal stuff um
but both of us realize that like
it's just sometimes you you say
something that maybe you shouldn't have
and sometimes someone asks you a
personal question you answer it because
you're off guard and
you know you can't really do much about
it it's just kind of the nature of the
beast
in uh in 24 hours it talks about how
fast
everything moved with camila is she your
forever person like do you talk about
an engagement one day yeah
absolutely i think for me it's always
been if i'm not willing to talk about
that stuff then i
kind of check out a little bit and um i
don't know i really think when you know
you know and
um she's been one of my best friends
since i was like 15 years old so
i don't know at the same time i know
we're really young so i don't want to
jump
like insanely fast but i think when you
find your person you feel and you know
that you found your person
what are you guys doing for the holidays
by the way i'm going uh back to canada
i'm going back home in five days
so much family time are you excited oh
my god we have a puppy
so and i'm going to my parents house so
camila and i are going to stay
in the basement at my parents house in
pickering ontario with a puppy it's
going to be super nice
that puppy is so cute by the way thanks
he's super cute
is it a lot of hard work it's like
having a baby it's like having a child
yeah well very cute congratulations the
album is amazing
i'm so excited for you and for people
thank you katie i appreciate you
you